hey what's up everyone my name is love
agarwal and i'm a data platform solution
engineer for ibm
machine learning there's no doubt that
this is an incredibly hot topic with
significant interest from both business
professionals
as well as technologists so let's talk
about what machine learning or
ml is so before we get too far into the
details i want to take a minute to talk
about some terms that are often used
interchangeably
but have certain differences terms like
artificial intelligence
machine learning and even
deep learning so at the highest level
ai is defined as leveraging computers or
machines to mimic the problem-solving
and the decision-making capabilities of
the human mind
and machine learning is a subset within
ai
that's more focused on the use of
various self-learning algorithms that
derive knowledge from data
in order to predict outcomes and then
finally deep learning
is a further subset within even machine
learning
and deep learning is often thought of as
scalable machine learning because it
automates a lot of the feature
extraction process away
and eliminates some of the human
intervention involved
to enable the use of some really really
big data sets
but for today we'll just focus on
machine learning so we'll get rid of the
other two
and dive one level deeper and talk about
the different types of machine learning
okay so the first type that we have is
called
supervised learning
and this is when we use labeled data
sets to train algorithms
to classify data or predict outcomes and
when i say labeled i mean that the rows
in the data set
are labeled tagged or classified in some
interesting way that tells us something
about that data
so it could be a yes or a no or it could
be a particular category
of some you know different attribute
okay
so how do we apply supervised machine
learning techniques
well this really depends on your
particular use case
we could be using a
classification model
which recognizes and groups ideas or
objects
into predefined categories an example of
this in the real world
is with customer
retention
so if you're in the business of managing
customers one of your goals is typically
minimizing and identifying customer
churn
right which are customers that no longer
buy a particular product
or service and we want to avoid churn
because it's almost
always more costly to acquire a new
customer
than it is to retain an existing one
right
so if we have historical data for the
customer
like their activity whether they churned
or not
right we can build a classification
model using supervised machine learning
and our label data set
that will help us identify customers
that are about to churn
and then allow us to take action to
retain them
okay so the other type of supervised
learning
is regression
now this is when we build an equation
using various input values with their
specific weights
determined by the overall value of their
impact
on the outcome and we use these to
generate an
estimate for an output value so let me
give you another example here
so airlines rely heavily on machine
learning
and they use regression techniques to
accurately predict how much they should
be charging for a particular flight
right so they use various input factors
like
you know days before departure the day
of the week the departure
the destination to
use these to predict an accurate dollar
value
for how much they should be charging for
a specific flight that will maximize
their revenue
okay so now let's move on to the second
type of machine learning
which is
unsupervised
learning
okay so this is when we use machine
learning algorithms
to analyze and cluster unlabeled data
sets
and this method helps us discover hidden
patterns or groupings without the need
for
human intervention right so we're using
unlabeled
data here so again let's talk about the
different techniques for unsupervised
learning
one method is clustering
and a real world example of this is when
organizations try to do
customer segmentation
right so when businesses businesses try
to do effective marketing
it's really critical that they really
understand who their customers are
right so that they can connect with them
in the most relevant way
and oftentimes it's not obvious or clear
how
certain customers are similar to or
different from one another
right and clustering algorithms can help
take into account
a variety of information on the customer
like
their purchase history
uh you know their their social media
activity or website activity
could be their geography and much
more to group similar customers into
buckets so that we can send them
more relevant offers provide them better
customer service
and be more targeted with our marketing
efforts
okay and the last point i want to touch
on for unsupervised learning
is called
dimensionality reduction
so we won't discuss this in detail in
this video but
this refers to techniques that reduce
the number of input variables in a data
set
so we don't let some redundant
parameters over represent
the impact on the outcome
okay so the last type of machine
learning i want to talk about today is
called
reinforcement learning
now this is a form of semi-supervised
learning where we typically have
an agent or system
take actions
in an environment
now the environment will then either
reward the agent for correct moves
or punish it for incorrect moves right
and through many
iterations of this we can teach a system
a particular task
now a great example of this method in
the real world is with self-driving cars
so autonomous driving has several
factors right there's the speed limit
there are drivable zones there are
collisions and so on
um so we can use forms of reinforcement
learning to teach a system how to drive
by avoiding collisions
following the speed limit and so on okay
so we covered many topics today but you
know we've barely scratched the surface
of each one
if you found any one particular aspect
of machine learning interesting i
encourage you to dive deeper and learn
more about it
and if you want to know what are some of
the common machine learning algorithms
and how to
and how to leverage them in data science
please check out some of the links in
the description
thank you if you have questions please
drop us a line below
and if you want to see more videos like
this in the future please like and
subscribe
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge with ibm cloud
labs which are free
browser-based interactive kubernetes
labs